Welcome to our lesson on creating
a professional GitHub profile.
I'm Mat Leonard,
a course developer at Udacity.
In this lesson you'll create or
update your GitHub profile for
use as a portfolio of your work.
You'll also learn how to impress
recruiters by contributing to open
source projects.
If you don't have experience with Git in
GitHub please take Udacity's course on
version control with git.
Just follow the link in
the instructor notes.
Then come back here when you're done,
and we'll work on your profile.
Artists use a portfolio to
hold examples of their work.
For instance, there's a couple
paintings in my portfolio.
I call this Octopus On A Swing,
and this is Two Cellos and a Baby.
Similarly, my GitHub profile is
a portfolio of my programming work.
You can use GitHub the same way.
To show off your work
to potential employers.
Your profile will also
show how you work.
Don't worry, we'll go through various
ways to make your GitHub profile
into a professional portfolio.